[موسيقى]
تتمتع برلين بسمعة طيبة حيث تكون ألمانيا
قوية ،
فهذه المدينة محفوفة بالمخاطر ، كما أن برلين
بعد ساعات العمل مكان مختلف تمامًا.
شكل من أشكال الفن في
إزالة ملابس المرء ، أوه
ستندهش من
عدم وصفه ، أعتقد أنه أكثر
أشكال الفن حداثة
لأنه يتعلق بمسائل
التوجه الجنسي والجنس والحرية الجنسية
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
حريات اليوم هي  متجذرة في الماضي المتسامح لبرلين ،
عش ودعنا نعيش
نتذكر الأيام المسكرة لجمهورية فايمار
المخربة للغاية في يومها والتي تم
تخليدها في الكاباريه الموسيقي
مع التخلص من
الأغلال المحافظة لعصر بيئة القيصر والإمبراطورية
في برلين ، ازدهرت الملاهي الليلية
لأن الناس كان لديهم  لا شيء للاحتفاظ
به ليس هناك وظائف ، الأمور تزداد سوءًا
وتزدهر هزلية ، نعم لا شيء
آخر تفعله ولا شيء آخر لبيعه
سوى تدفقهم  أجسادًا ،
لذا فإن أولئك الذين كانوا أكثر حظًا وأكثر
جمالا أو لديهم بعض المواهب يجب أن يصعدوا
إلى المسرح وربما يفعلون شيئًا سعيدًا
مثل الملهى ، فما هو فن القيام
بذلك - أنت طاووس جيدًا ، الطاووس
هو دجاجة صغيرة حقًا
ملون بشكل محرج ولكن بمجرد أن
يفتح الذيل كنت مثل الرئيس ،
إنه جميل جدًا إنه مجرد شخص واحد
إذا كنت تختلف في انحراف شخص واحد فقط
يخلع ملابسه على شيء هائل في
بعض الأحيان كنت
مخيفًا للغاية لقد عملت بجد على ذلك نعم
حسنًا ، أنت تقول إنك نجحت إذا
نظرت إلى برلين اليوم ، فهي تبدو
نائمة على ما يبدو ، إنها عاصمة
تشعر وكأنها مدينة فهي بطيئة جدًا ،
إنها مريحة جدًا لأنها كانت
مكتظة بالسكان على نطاق واسع ، وفي الآونة الأخيرة ،
أصبحت هذه الوتيرة  حتى في
العام الماضي ، لا تزال هناك مدينة
يسير فيها أي شيء ،
ماذا يعني ذلك ، إنها
عبارة صغيرة جميلة ولكن ما الذي
يعنيه أنها مجرد حرية
التعايش في هذه المدينة وأنت لديك
هذا  الجدات الألمانيات rgeois
يرتدون الفراء واللؤلؤ وكان لديك كل
هؤلاء الأمهات في الملعب مع
الأوشام على أعناقهن والمجدالات
التي يقودها الجانب الذي يقود برلين في
الوقت الحالي أعتقد أنهما يسيران
معًا وهذا سحر
ملهى برلين سيظل دائمًا  كن إرثًا
لهذه المدينة والآن هناك شيء
تضيفه إلى النوادي الليلية في وجهك ، فهم
يأتون إلى هنا من جميع أنحاء العالم
للحفلات ولسبب رئيسي واحد هو أن
تقني ، ليالي النادي ، دي جي ومشهد الفينيل ،
يمنحون برلين
مجتمعها Crowl مثل  عاصمة تكنو
للعالم ، انتقلت منسقة الأغاني بيغي غيو إلى برلين لرفع مستوى
لعبتها اليوم وهي تلعب أمام حشود من جميع
أنحاء العالم لم أفهم
تقنية ديجاننا لكن برلين جعلتني
أفهم أنني أدرس في لندن
ولكن برلين قامت بترقيتي بيغي جوو
ANOVA أو على النقيض باختصار
تكنو كورية وروسية وبرلين هي
المرحلة التي يتشاركونها